[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le poids bien dressés l'époque un
gréement ont traduit les chansons der
monde en joual
[Musique]
depuis le début des années 2000 que
j'avais pensé avec un ancien colocataire
puisqu'elle est à vous d'y avoir pensé
il fallait le faire
il y figure mythique du punk rock avec
quelques accords seulement les romands
ont créé de grands succès en 40 ans les
albums des romans ont fait le tour du
monde et les farc un gréement sont des
fans finis et on en a mauvaise jouer là
bas mon espèce d'énergie humaine qui
mesurerait huit pieds il est tout croche
mais tellement intense et tellement
sensuel à foix est tellement dans cet
effort de traduction
la chanson originale rockaway beach est
devenu plage jean doré et il y en a
d'autres
la première c'était la plus faste
sainte-catherine champlain qui était
fictif heures enter faites vos
recherches
h2 rocha cette mouture québécoise des
roses a vu le jour il ya moins d'un an
contrairement aux apparences il ne
s'agit pas d'une mince tâche très simple
mais c'est pas si simple que ça j'ai
passé le temps 60 tel match on les a
brand par cas
[Musique]
la famille faut aller un jour de travail
mais bon hamamouche au trou